the reason that it's humans that are
calling the shots on planet Earth and
where the fate of other species are
ultimately up to us is because of our
intelligence and generally our cognitive
abilities our ability to work with each
other to achieve goals and what we're
planning on doing or at least the AI
researchers are is developing new
entities that are better than us at this
unique attribute so I think the default
pathway there unless we do anything to
prevent it would be that it's ultimately
these new things that are calling the
shots
so that's one way to look at it and then
if you say what can you do in order to
ensure that they're aligned with our
interests or that they can always obey
our instructions the people who are
working on that particular part of
artificial intelligence called AI
alignment research that they're actually
leading the concern that we're not going
to be able to develop those techniques
in time and that will have systems that
are more powerful than us before we have
systems that we know how to control